fei world cup voglio tenere il settaggio
horror per questo gioco perché un po
horror alla fine ha fatto tre episodi
sub auge anche se effettivamente a
pensarci ma poi c'e una cosa ci trovi io
ho fatto i bisogni mille episodi anche
gli sui motori dreams quindi di che cosa
vi scandalizzate primo secondo questo
gioco è la mia felicità
ok io trovo in questo gioco degli amici
come avete visto negli altri bisogni che
non trova nella vita reale quindi è
incredibile il fatto che ci possa essere
ci possono essere persone con le quali
dialogare in un gioco del genere guarda
come stringo amicizia facilmente guarda
vuoi essere mio amico porco demonio se
ci riuscivo sarebbe stato incredibile
porca vacca tanto alla fine ancora non
ho capito al come vi ho detto l'ultima
volta credo che l'obiettivo sia cercare
di colpire l'avversario con una roccia
che faccia il più danno possibile che
una roccia che abbia più punti possibili
perché non è più il giocare come dice
l'ultima volta ma il capire il
funzionamento ad esempio adesso questa
l'ho colpito una roccia che vale 3
ok quindi o tre punti se lui mi colpisce
come lo sa che vale 9 lui arriva a 9
quindi non è quante volte lo butti giù
ma comunque quanti punti accumuli credo
sia questo poi non lo so e se invece di
fini una botta di call con le mani non
so quanto che forse non prendi nessun
punto serve solo per distrarre 4 quindi
in totale sono sette
io teorica me non lo so e non so se ho
capito bene nel funzionamento di sta
roba però credo che sia effettivamente
così è la my friends whatsapp madonna
tramite in due non riusciamo a fare una
cosa dei 100 madonna quanto deve essere
difficile colpire la gente
stai fermo a 5 non ho capito come
funziona
continua non capì aiaf ma è proprio in
questa dove i respawn aree che palle
allora hai capito come si gioca tutti
gli prendere le rocce tirarli faccia
vedere non sto facendo niente il
successo sta roba da sola non ho fatto
nulla per caso perché stava andando
molto bene il film erotico
buongiorno a lei salve aia porco del
demonio non ho visto quanti punti ha
fatto però numero dice mi scusi le
sembra il modo
prendi questo porca vacca altramente
adesso andiamo veramente c'è
competizione zio questo qua è forte ma
io sono più fa cup
cosa le onde concentriche io oggi ho de
vizia che botta due però gli elevate
pochissimo forse spa un'acqua no spam
madonna come rischiato lo zio matto
frate madonna io ho durando oddio è una
roccia bianca cosa vuol dire ai a queste
bianca per quale motivo c'è razzismo
pure sulle rocce occhio cori coari
fratello madonna ha omaggiato di un
niente aiuto ai a tre punti in totale
non so non ho capito non ho visto ei
fate porca eva beh mi pare che quando
stand di qualcuno non prendi punti
teoricamente a da invece ne prendi 5 no
sapevo
prendo questo e tela lancio laggiù vai a
nuovi team ei no taito preso mato preso
non è vero non ho preso provincia né una
lancia nei una sola madonna ho rischiato
tantissimo non ci proviene anche a
perché fuori non riesce a prenderlo
eccolo ovvio che stava lì occhio che fa
la riprova ci diano subito
no provate vista kilar lo cicero così
riuscito mancano sette secondi occhio
porca vacca non si capisce le cose sono
troppo fuori e l'ho preso no l'ho
colpito la figlia l'ho capito loro
compito partita finita va bene va bene
ho vinto e la pareggio ma l'ho colpito a
partita finita quindi ho vinto è di
questo che fai non lo fai con te allora
non ho ancora capito come mai si finisce
in pareggio
pronto pronto a un altro filosofo jean
avatar di file credo quindi questo è
preso bene quei combattimenti ma guarda
me non a me non mi pare non mi faccio
sorprendere non ho paura di te sei un ca
ga sotto lo sarai tu non io ma come la
schivato ma dai ma che cura la prima
partita questo perché questo è
combattivo
non mi ha preso mai nella vita non mi ha
preso mai ma proprio ma neanche il bene
anche time ad mettete in un giudice a
fastello tipo di gerio mariotto come
combattermi nato ho perso
come c'era 26 rocce per terra nova siri
i ragazzi non sto capendo sul gioco come
funziona l'ho colpito più volte non
capisco come funziona questo gioco ma
basta non capisco funzionamento non
capisco ma perché adesso due colpi e
finisce la partita tra l'altro stavo 22
adesso quindi erano pari ma come mi
chiamo se in due colpi ti giuro non
muore 11 non siamo in due ed efficienti
ci siamo alzate vicenda ok siamo 1 a 1
molin conto perché non è possibile ma
era rimbalzo si può fare di sporchi
hillary di rimbalzo dai sti ho preso in
testa piena
minchia le volte ameni uccide non mi
prende neanche a me mi non si dice ma
chi se ne frega a me il mio di conto
voglio madonna meno male ei precisione 1
a 0 proprio lui dov'è amica dietro ma
dai
io ero rimasto rimasto fermo tutto il
tempo bellis vincitore
non comprendo ho finalmente vinto una
partita che non ho capito perché ho
vinto ragazzi basta
giochiamo senza un conte tanto non è
affatto a caso sto gioco inutile che
tentò di spiegarmi cosa sta succedendo
non si capisce quindi le slot bel avatar
zio
beh mi sono andate bene le ultime due
estranei è stato istantaneamente un
veterano di questo gioco doveva fare
l'ultima tanto anche se non ho capito
come si vince in 3 episodi è tre episodi
di gioco ancora un capitolo si vince
prova contro sentenza l'italiano va bene
essendo italiano ha visto il mio nome e
si è sottomesso l'ex co questo è
l'ultimo combattimento serio e ragazzi
dopo quattro vittorie sono tranquillo
ecco minchia se fosse non ci fosse stata
la bollina rimani lato ei cosa chi sta
succedendo ragazzi spiegatemi se non che
non crei un capisco non capisco non
capisco non lo capisco adesso vinco e
basta prima perde basta allora
decidetevi facciamo questo è l'ultimo è
questo è l'ultimo perché ormai è
diventato un
non sense segoni prima che ci sia troppa
gente e gioioso gioco stranamente mi
chiedo proprio il perché quello di
capriati 6 sottomesso ma adesso per il
ai madonna che l'ho mancato subito e
figurate ciao bello non mi hai preso
però bel tiro qua io ti ho preso invece
e non ti ha buttato giù però fa niente
eccolo proprio lui lo punisce minchia
bellissimo tiro anticipato subito dovrò
fare una roba tipo votate nei commenti
chi si meritava la partita che se non un
senso a maledizione non vedo l'ora
cimetti di una molto gentile dai
cazzotti in bocca dato perdo io tanto
perdo io perdo io tanto vico si sente
schifoso viene svelato del carpe dato di
merda brutto stop dei caf lato di me
testa di ca a posto ma no ma come ma
tipo entrato mi ha tirato una testata
sono morto come minimo questa finisce in
pareggio che sta vincendo io come sempre
ecco bravo ti ho fatto lo sgambetto con
attenzione
bellissima proprio lui lo punisce a ci
ho riprovato punito due volte vista
partita è la ma tira tira perché non ho
tirato bene sono svenuto prendi questo
l'ho preso
ho vinto io anche se effettivamente non
ho capito ma signori trovati al pensate
è talmente bello so ciò che siamo al
terzo episodio senza bisogno di pounds
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa dice che
mi piace anche marito c'è alcun dato
dalla stazione se non sente quesiti
iscrivetevi come sempre ci teniamo a
locazioni bella ragazzi
[Musica]